[Music]  how Brad Pitt is getting his Hollywood  groove back the star took a bit of a  step back from the spotlight after he  and Angelina Jolie split but apparently  he is getting back together with friends  old and new a source tells ET brad has  more time now he has been in touch with  most of his friends throughout this  whole deal the source also adds brad is  getting back into shape and works out  regularly but is currently not dating  meanwhile Angelina has got a new job as  a teacher et has learned that in  September the 41 year old mom of six  will be a visiting professor at the  London School of Economics and she'll  travel back and forth so with the  divorce moving forward and both stars  leading separate lives is this  Brangelina's new normal a source tells  BTW brad is doing his thing and angie is  doing hers they have both put the media  drama behind them  [Music]